Logitech has jumped into the gaming
handheld Market that's currently
dominated by steam deck Xbox has put out
a new update and Playstation Studios
games aren't coming to subscriptions day
and date anytime soon all this on
today's Gamespot news
Logitech has a gaming handheld that can
play games like Halo infinite grounded
sea of Thieves and Forza Horizon 5 but
there's a catch it's all done via
streaming via services like Xbox cloud
gaming and GeForce now this device will
allow you to take your games on the go
as long as you have a Wi-Fi connection
because there's zero options for
cellular if you're asking yourself is
there anything this can do that my phone
with a controller grip can't the answer
is no there seemingly isn't and if you
own a handheld like the steam deck that
can play dedicated PC games those
devices also allow you to access the
same streaming services although the
process to set them up is a little more
complicated there is one area that the
Logitech gcloud gaming handheld succeeds
in and that is battery life if you don't
want to drain your phone's power
logitech's handheld will provide up to
12 hours of battery life it also Sports
a 7-inch 10 ADP LCD screen with a 60hz
refresh rate you'd think with a price
tag of 350 dollars matching the OLED
switch it would pack an OLED screen but
on the console side Xbox has put out a
fun update for its users with this
latest update you'll be able to change
the Xbox button color on any Series 2
Elite controller alongside this Xbox has
released its Elite Series 2 core
controller a white version of the device
that excludes additional items such as
the back pedals and swappable
thumbsticks for a lower price point of
130 those items can be purchased in an
additional accessory pack for sixty
dollars there's been a library revamp
streamlined to show you all the games
you have access to install and play as
well as an all games section which will
include games you can play through any
subscriptions you have like a Game Pass
EA access and games with gold you can
now choose different installation
locations for your games and apps on
Xbox series X and S and Xbox One
consoles for example you can let your
Xbox decide where optimized for Xbox
series XS games will go you can choose
to install Backward Compatible games on
an external hard drive and put apps on
internal storage Xbox game bar has a new
option to get a shareable link for any
captures of your game you take on PC you
can do so Via SMS WhatsApp Twitter
messenger and more and if your settings
are public then anyone will be able to
check out your captures at PlayStation
the company's head of Indies Shuhei
Yoshida said in an interview with game
industry.biz that Sony still believes in
the quote premium release of a title at
launch and that when those games are
made available on the new PS plus Tis
the aim is to give those titles an
additional Revenue stream much later in
their life cycles there are exceptions
to the rule such as the day one launches
of multi play eccentric games such as
Rocket league and four guys so that they
could quickly establish an online
audience so yeah don't expect God of War
Ragnarok to launch day and state via
PlayStation Plus even on its most
expensive tier something that you won't
have to pay for is Call of Duty's next
open Beta weekend while playing it on
Xbox or PC on September 22nd and 23rd
will either require a pre-order or a
code giveaway from an outlet or streamer
the beta will be open to all players on
all platforms starting on Saturday
September 24th through 26th and that is
it for today's Gamespot news are you one
of the niche Gamers I spoke about that
is actually interested in logitech's
streaming focused handheld let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
here tomorrow for more Gamespot news
[Music]